il aura suffi de quelques mots pour
raviver ce que certains à droite
considèrent encore comme un hold up
politique lors d'une commission d'
enquête sur les obstacles à
l'indépendance du pouvoir judiciaire et
leanne houlette est auditionné l'ancien
procureur financières et notamment
interrogés sur la sphère fillon elle y
détaille alors les requêtes exprimées à
l'époque par le procureur général
les demandes de chronologie général tout
ça à deux jours d'intervalle awa trois
jours demande éléments sur les auditions
demande de notes des conseils des
mis-en-cause réunion réunion j'ai été
convoqués au parquet général parce que
le choix de procéder de procédure le
choix procédural que j'avais adopté ne
convenait pas pour m'engager à changer
de voie procédurale à dire d'ouvrir une
information et j'ai d'ailleurs une
dépêche j'ai reçu une dépêche des
procureurs a dans ce sens on ne peut que
se poser des questions la décision est
rôle très étroit c'est un contrôle très
étroit et c'est une pression très lourde
une pression très lourde
les mots sont lâchés de ces déclarations
découle une question y aurait-il eu une
quelconque intervention politique
derrière les procédures engagées contre
françois fillon lors de la campagne
présidentielle de 2017
c'est visiblement ce que pensent
certains eliane ouled certainement un
peu dépassé par la portée de ces
déclarations est revenu sur ses propos
dans les colonnes du monde
selon elle la pression dont elle parle
n'est pas politique mais uniquement
exercée par le parquet général sur le
choix procédural
malgré ce rétropédalage la polémique
n'est pas éteinte
pour preuve certains demandent des
comptes au point que l'elysée doivent
réagir en annonçant saisir le conseil
supérieur de la magistrature à farges
site d'analysé si le parquet national
financier a pu exercer son activité en
toute sérénité sans pression dans le
cadre d'un dialogue normal et habituel
avec le parquet général
interrogé par le journal du dimanche
nicole belloubet garde des sceaux
justifie ce choix
les propos de l'ancien procureur
financière on
à tort ou à raison distiller le doute
sur l'indépendance et l'impartialité de
la justice dans la conduite de cette
affaire
un doute qui existait déjà alimenté par
différentes révélations sur les
coulisses de cette affaire fillon
certains sionistes estime que l'élection
aurait été faussée eric ciotti y voit
par exemple la preuve d'une grande
manipulation dont le but était d'abattre
le candidat de la droite républicaine
ce sentiment selon lequel la chute
orchestrée ou non de françois fillon
aurait pu influer sur le résultat final
de la présidentielle est partagée
notamment par nicolas dupont aignan qui
en vient à remettre en cause la
légitimité des manuels macron même les
anciens rivaux de françois fillon lors
de cette élection en l'occurrence marine
le pen et jean luc mélenchon ont réagi
aux déclarations de madame houlette y
voyant une énième illustration d'une
forme d'instrumentalisation de la
justice dont ils disent même avoir fait
les frais c'est donc un dossier
éminemment politique qui s'est rouvert
mais ce débat coïncide aussi avec
l'agenda judiciaire
le jugement de la faire pour laquelle le
couple fillon a déjà été entendue doit
être rendu le 29 juin dans tout juste
une semaine